the layer heil pen show
[Music]
sponsored by step finance
your go to d5 portfolio manager on
solana
luna if you're just getting into bitcoin
it's the perfect place to start
hey guys and welcome back to the leia
high plan show as usual it is powered by
icon plus capital they're a vc firm and
it is sponsored by blockfi so i'm very
excited to get into this we are talking
about one of my favorite stories i think
it is definitely actually my favorite
story um when it comes to crypto
especially in the last two years so
joining me on the show today is jamie
ragozinski the founder of wall street
bets jamie welcome to the show how you
doing good thank you how are you doing
leia
i'm good i'm good i just when i say what
happened last year with the whole robin
hood scandal um that was one of my
favorite one of my favorite things i've
ever seen in the space i have to be
honest well it's certainly one of the
craziest things that i've seen as well
right like you've seen a lot of
efforts throughout the years where
people of wall street bets decide to do
some shenanigans and they're extremely
clever and they're building on this
knowledge but as they grew
in size and in knowledge they were able
to pull off really what is the perfect
storm
absolutely so for those that don't know
um i know you've probably told the story
a bunch of times but there's more people
that haven't there's still plenty of
people that haven't heard it so just
briefly give us the overview um we'll
start with what is wall street bets give
us the overview of all street bets first
so wall street bets is a community it's
most notably known for the subreddit uh
called wall street bets but it's grown
to have this omnipresence all over
social media so these are it's kind of
like a mindset community of people that
hang out and use the markets in a way
that's really high risk or as the name
implies like a casino right they're
trying to find these high propensity
uh you know high risk high return trades
and oftentimes that results in people
losing money but uh
oftentimes it also results in people
making crazy amounts of money as well
and just over a year ago the community
decided to take on wall street because
you guys were sort of tired of feeling
like the little man and you wanted to
have some fun is that a good way to
phrase it
you know that's kind of how the media
ended up playing because it sounds sexy
that way right like you have the
retailers you have the david and the
goliath and it just sounds it sounds
nice like that it's true it's definitely
not
not true but like throughout the years
as wall street bets
continue to grow you'd have a lot of
instances where they'd say oh look i
just found this really cool what's
called arbitrage opportunity which is a
fancy word for like a you know
relatively low risk uh free money type
trade and they would really creative and
sometimes it would take tremendous
amounts of risk
not so much with the actual risk return
of the trade but getting in trouble with
regulators or brokers because they would
basically find kind of like loopholes so
what happened with gamestop was
you have this guy uh keith gill or deep
i don't know if you can curse your
effing value
i think you can it's up to youtube okay
uh and or rory and kitty and on on
youtube he had this this philosophy so i
like gamestop for all these different
reasons took this massive like fifty
thousand dollar trade using stock
options which is pretty risky
and all of a sudden his his uh trade
starts making a lot of money and it
starts getting a lot of attention and
people start piling on and then all of a
sudden the hedge funds come out and say
oh we're short you know this thing is
not worth anything the pandemic blah
blah blah right and so you start getting
the stage of
all the people on one side being kind of
challenged right like and the hedge
funds on the other saying you can't
touch me over this is my playground you
can't
there's nothing you can do here right
and uh and sure enough they ended up
making so much money like they they
bought the stocks and they did it very
sophisticated with stock options with
gamma squeezes like it was a lot more
than just people purchasing stocks uh
and it ended up basically taking the
price of gamestop from was about
about five dollars earlier
the year prior about forty dollars at
the beginning of this of last year all
the way up to like 500 it was the
highest they got in the after hours
trading so you know obviously that cost
a lot of money to the hedge funds
because they had to close out their
short positions about 70 billion i think
it was 70. well that's a lot um okay
what was that i don't know yeah 70
billion just sounds like it's very
possible right like i i don't know what
it was uh but but it definitely was in
the billions i know that much so
you know it was this this idea of
finally the retail people are here you
have to pay attention to us make room
for us at this poker table we may be
belligerent but you know we can push
your your chip stack around
yeah it was just truly fascinating and i
think the fact that um you know robin
hood started um you know halting the
trading so people couldn't actually um
they couldn't buy they could sell but
they couldn't buy
what was the
what was the
atmosphere like on all street bets at
the time because i'm not part of the
community i don't actually use reddit um
so what was it like
so
you know this this thing with robin hood
stopping trading it's this kind of
misconceived it's a misconception as to
what happened yes they did stop trading
and so that fact is correct uh but
oftentimes it's painted as well
the little guys were winning robin and i
had to put a stop to the bleeding and
there's enough conspiracies that you can
link the way that robin hood gets their
money to one of these payment for order
flow companies that's that's the one
that handles this transaction that ends
up bailing out one of these funds
uh so so there was just definitely a lot
to work with but at the end of the day
it was a regulatory issue and all
brokers had to basically stop trading
game stuff right like this is a thing
that's complicated it deals with the
settlement process and how it takes
forever and then you know these clearing
houses
require collateral from these really
volatile stocks so like robin hood had
to come up with like three billion
dollars overnight to be able to allow
trading right so
and they did and they effectively did
come up with the three billion dollars
but during that that 24 hour period they
had to stop but that doesn't stop them
from being to some extent uh
guilty of not foreseeing this you know
certainly it was
one of a kind incident but still they
should have seen the writing on the wall
maybe have more cash on hand who knows
the feeling on wall street bets was
absolutely like what are you doing to me
and it was all against robin hood mainly
because robin hood was the biggest
broker that people were using
um and there was definitely a lot of
animosity
yeah i mean it was good fun for the
whole community just you know people who
were sort of i don't mean to say
anti-establishment but like
auntie the traditional way of doing
things right um i want to take the power
back in whatever way it was good fun for
us to sort of see that narrative play
out see you know really just wall street
push an entire generation into whether
it's crypto or decentralization or well
it feels good to be empowered you know
you have
younger people as a whole
i mean even for when you're a child it's
like you can't eat your candy before
dinner you know you've been told kind of
what to do there's very little influence
you can do maybe throw a tantrum who
knows you know then when you're in in
high school maybe college it's like i
want to be able to do these things but i
don't have the money whatever and the
boss has to tell me because i'm a junior
level you know you're just used to to
being the the nobody in the scene and
this particular group of people which
was young
were had been marginalized by the 2008
financial crisis you know you have a lot
of people with this mindset and
sometimes you see people go out and
protest sometimes people do different
things and this was like this really
clever way of hitting these banks where
it hurts you know you had the 2008
financial crisis where
people were occupying wall street and
they put their tents up there and they
lived there forever and
you know it didn't do anything it just
it was just it got some attention to the
news it didn't elicit any type of change
but this was effective right and this
was
hey
look there's there is a way to to be
heard and absolutely it felt really good
and of course you have the component of
the rivalry right like
people in general are tribal right they
like to be republican or democrat or
they like to go for you know one
football team or the other football team
and it's always going to be i'm going to
beat you whatever it is now you had a
good guy and a bad guy and it was the
hedge funds that were perfect story put
their face out there and these these
people that were really enjoying beating
them
it's just it's just the perfect story
but i'd like to get some of your
background um because i know you do have
a a background in traditional finance so
you have a natural finance background is
that right
sort of i studied uh
dual major economics and uh computer
engineering
and then eventually once i started i was
actually so yeah it was around the time
i started wall street bets that i'd
started a masters in finance
um you know i i figured hey the stock
market you literally click things and
you make money and
it's kind of like a video game and it
really is
so i'm going to study finance that i can
figure and so then i'm learning about
discounted cash flows and you know like
time value of money these crazy concepts
i'm like okay well which point do you
tell me whether to short or long the
stock right yeah and there were there
was none of that there were just there
were just math equations that really
didn't apply and when i would try to
apply it it's like well apple's
valuation according to the book value do
these excel analysis and all of a sudden
apple's doing crazy things because
whatever president tweets or you know
things that have nothing to do with my
excel so i'm like all right well that
was a waste of time all right i'm just
going to figure out how to play with the
stock market by just using it like a
game and
and so while i do have that formal
background and the the formal
understanding of finance i also have the
hands-on experience of saying like look
in the long term you can apply some
finance rules if that's how you want to
do it but if you're just looking to make
money or play or experiment or
uh whatever it is like you literally
you're looking at a line that goes up
and down on the screen and based off of
a gut feeling or if you've stared at
enough charts you kind of get a
a feel for whether it's going to go up
or down
are you looking at like the fundamentals
of a company or are you looking at
geopolitics you know you're saying
you're not looking at excel spreadsheets
so what is it no i'm not looking at
anything well geopolitics kind of
because that's uh catalyst type news
right like if you have
you know
russia yeah russia is kind of a tricky
one because we've already had russia
before we've had china before we have
all these big kind of but there's
there's some much more specific ones uh
that
that they could tip the scale something
that has to do with oil is like i don't
know some some countries whatever and
then that'll shoot the price up and down
so that that's relevant but the
fundamentals isn't because
my time frame is like you know a couple
minutes or a couple hours or a couple
days at most and a lot a lot of times
people use stock options or in my case
futures which revolves so like the
fundamentals don't matter between like
you know 9 30 a.m and 9 30 6 a.m right
like these high frequency computers that
also trade all day long they're they're
not reading discounted cash flows look
at the statistics and how things move
and
and so so
occasionally i enjoy for like academic
purposes reading fundamentals of the
company but i don't necessarily map that
to
um what the stock is doing
so if you you know you've got i totally
understand that makes sense you know if
you're if you're a bit of a gamer it
makes sense why you would sort of see
the stock market like that i think
that's a smart way to look at it so you
know if you if you sort of dedicated
your
your education to that right you said
you did a masters right yes if you
dedicate your education to that that's a
lot of money you truly must you know
believe in it so what point did you
realize that it was rich
no i do i like it's
i wanted to study just you know what
when you go to school you get this piece
of paper you hang on your wall and then
you give it to the guy over there and
then he gives you a job and he gives you
more money right that's really what it's
about like it's not
engineering school like computer
engineering that i really did it because
i wanted to gain the knowledge and i did
believe that and a lot of that stuff and
like the intellectual challenge and same
with economics uh but with finance it
was literally just a professional place
like all right well i'm working the
system and i got a job and i want more
money so i got to do this thing so it's
it was more of just this this
traditional
type of investment in myself but
but i always but i but i never was a
very fundamental believer
of it i probably started becoming
disillusioned in like
2006-ish there about when i first
started kind of playing with the stock
market
and and things would just do things that
don't make sense right you have pre and
you see it so often now it's like why
did the price go down they just beat
earnings or whatever
um
it's just so frequent i'm like all right
uh clearly there's a disconnect and you
see what happens in 2008 shenanigans and
all the the
damage that it caused right people
actually losing their houses isn't
things that these aren't no longer the
lines that move on their screen or in
addition to being lines they're
affecting
my i actually lost my job because of the
2008 crisis so what were you doing to
work at the time i was working at a
financial services company
um and and
it's so anyway so you have you have
i had this disillusionment i'm like all
right well this thing is clearly just a
toy for people to play with and i and i
know that some people do this
professionally where they stare at their
screen and click and make money i would
like to do that too and i don't want to
be able to depend on having a master's
degree or whatever i hedge my bets with
the masters but
so that's when it became apparent and
the more i learned about it the more i
realized this really is a game like you
have to find cheat codes you have to
find
they have fancy words for it like i said
earlier arbitrage but you can use a meme
instead of you know like a math formula
to describe what's happening and it can
be just as effective and so these
these cheat codes and there's been lots
of them that are found by these really
creative people that don't
want to play by the same rules like
here's an example in
2019 late 2019 thereabouts
uh this guy figured out that on robin
hood you can basically get infinite
margin meaning like infinite buying
power right and so this guy would it's a
little technical not too bad he would
basically buy a covered call like he
would buy 100 shares and sell a call and
and use his shares as collateral and
then robin hood kind of screwed up the
math behind what happens next because he
gets the money for the call and they
didn't lock it up and blah blah blah so
because of the because margin doubles
your money in the account he all of a
sudden had twice the buying power so he
did it two more times and he has four
times of buying power etcetera and and
the other and and then of course the
first thing that comes up through that
is i'm going to share this on the
internet with my friends so people like
oh let's see how let's see who wins and
there's like the roster of who's got the
biggest margin and people taking off
million dollar trades
and here's the arb on that one right
like the arb is alright fine now you
have a million dollars what do you bet
on they're like i don't care apple
earnings who knows because it's not my
money i'm you know banks are too big to
fail i'm too small to collect on so this
is a free ticket if i make money it's
mine
if i lose money
robin hood can't come after me because
they're in trouble for letting me get
away with this and so that's that's the
type of arb that you're not going to see
jp morgan do because there's jp morgan
but that's what you can see from a
college kid so uh and that's what makes
this a game and that's what really does
make this a lot of fun
it's just so fascinating to me
especially because you know it there
there are these cheat codes and there is
this community which i mean i know we
were sort of saying that the media likes
to present in a certain way but
ultimately it is sort of about you know
the little guy having an opportunity to
make as much money as the big guy can
make so
in what way do you think this is sort of
going to bring a new generation into
stocks because from my perspective you
know the internet you know forums like
yours are
inspiring and educating and empowering
a whole new generation because usually
this seems like something just reserved
for the older guys
yeah and that's that's always kind of
been the feeling right this is the this
veil of sophistication they can have put
on a tie in a suit
you know i say no no no you can't do
this here and uh
and they use these fancy
multi-syllabic words to
try and hide the sophistication but like
it's not it's a line on a screen and it
bounces right so as soon as people
figure that out they're like oh okay um
i'd say the combination between
social media right having people have
places like boston best where people can
come and chat and share
uh as well as the
the brokers that start becoming a first
discount and eventually free in terms of
commissions so now
and then you have things like um
fractional shares so that you can buy
little pieces of expensive shares if you
don't have a lot of money no minimum
anything
so pretty much you got 20 bucks you can
open a broker and you can just pretty
much start playing around with that and
that's pretty huge
that and the interface too it's just
this gamified thing where you know if
you want like robin hood did a lot of
things really really smart their
interface
if you want to buy stock options they're
complicated right there's like
differential equations that explain all
these greek values and how they move
around
but but robin hood just said hey um you
want to buy stock options cool uh do you
think the stock is good what stock do
you like apple why do you think do you
think it's going to go up or down and
then you answer with like a color-coded
arrow
and you say up and it says okay cool the
one you want is calls instead of puts
and then it says how much do you think
it's going to go up by right and then
you'll give it a thing and now now it
selects what's called a strike price
then it says when do you think it's
going to go up by and then and then you
put click that button it says all right
this is the thing you want to buy
and it's simplified something that is
insanely difficult
and like three easy and then you get
confetti animation congratulations you
bought your first stock option
like that's cool that's
that's amazing because i i've always
been sort of somewhat disillusioned with
the establishment um but i never really
understood finance at all
how can you right like you know a lot
about it in school um so i just didn't
understand it so my way through was
through bitcoin but i would absolutely
love um
you know i love things like that i think
that's amazing but
because they're simplifying it so much
how important would you say is
for people to actually get involved in
the stock market and learn how to trade
uh
that that's a broad question how it
depends on what people want to do with
themselves like if i think it's
important that they experiment so that
they know what it's about right at some
point
uh people will get jobs they'll want to
make money they'll want to invest in
their retirement they're not going to
get these like roth ira these whatever
index funds
or just diversified investment and
that's cool that works too right that's
the responsible thing to do if you have
a thousand bucks you're never going to
be a millionaire right so you can
experiment to play with that if you have
you know 50 000 bucks you probably
should put it away so that you can
retire nicely
there that that's where having some
experience of the stock market can help
you
navigate that part of your life so in
that in that sense
the important part is there
but there's another component whereas
people want to say okay well it's not
just that i want to know how to retire
i'd actually like to supplement my
income or replace my income
and that's where you say well look
anything that's finance related
is going to help you out and playing
with the stock market doesn't mean
going in and understanding what these
you know ratio these financial ratios of
the price to earning and bubble you know
it just means reading about it look at
the stuff buy the stock you want right
don't spend too much money but just buy
it look how it behaves figure out why
it's behaving that way and get a feel
for it don't get afraid
and uh and that helps you get experience
for all sorts of things like the
emotional component of when you lose
money like oh no my thing is down five
percent today
um don't freak out and sell maybe you
should buy more whatever
and that's not just stocks right you
mentioned bitcoin that's it's the same
thing it's it's just
an asset whose value is driven by a
number of people that are buying and
selling it and then that results in a
thing going up or down and you can
basically bet if it's going to go up or
down and if you're long term you want to
do it a certain way if you're short term
there's there's different ways to try
and get more
leverage out of your trade
you mentioned um you know not being
emotional about it so if there are
people out there even like myself who i
have never touched the stock market i
fully just crypto
what tips would you would you give
people in terms of you know where to
start but it's the same thing it's no
it's no different if you've been trading
crypto like there's not you're not going
to get a different feeling in your gut
when you're losing money
the the lines but if i want to make
money
like how do you do that
just be aware if you're making money
that's there's also a danger there if
you're like yay look what i did i'm
gonna be a billionaire you just like
start fantasizing about how you just
need to repeat that exactly 365 days ago
and by the time you're whatever age
you're gonna have two billion
so and then that gets you to do things
that are also silly so both making money
and losing money is this this uh
judgment cloud
you know how you make money with
stocks is gonna be a similar answer to
how you make money with crypto if you're
doing things with crypto you can buy the
coin and you can see if it goes up
uh or you can start doing some of these
defy exercises where you can buy the
thing and you're going to farm it and
stake it and liquidity pools and
generate yields and
you can do that kind of stuff with it or
you can do leveraged things like there's
options and futures and these binary
there's a lot of creative things in d5
stocks is the same thing you have like a
bunch of tools it says all right what do
you think do you like this thing this
company you think it's gonna go up
cool buy it and then wait and then hope
you're right and so that's
like buying a coin you want to do
something a little more exciting check
out these derivatives check out these
financial instruments and you can do
some really fun stuff especially if you
use like stock options
it's it's not even about guessing the
direction of the price sometimes you can
actually make money
if you think this the price is going to
stay where it is all right stock options
allow you to do that you buy some and
you sell something there's puts and
there's calls and you just you put this
trade together in such a way that
that if the price stays the same way you
actually end up making money
right so it gives you more
kind of uh
outcomes that you can guess on
how to make money with stocks if you if
you want the real answer like yeah they
go off right like zoom out to 19
whatever as long as
whatever finance tool you like to use
lets you go and the stock used to be
really low and the stock right now is
really really high
and it crashed in 2008 and it crashed in
2000 in 1987 and tooth and 1930 whatever
29
um but then it went back up right so if
you literally just want to invest and
make money then just buy stocks and just
keep buying stocks and you're going to
make money it's it's
pretty it's a pretty darn close to
certainty thing based on the fact that
basically population is growing right
like it's a crazy way to end up that way
but it's that same thing that you have
with bitcoin where it's like well this
thing's limited to however 21 million
coins and
also the population is growing and
therefore you can have more more demand
and
kind of a fixed supply and that's pretty
much what it boils down to
yeah and then what is also huge right
now is internet culture and from my
perspective that is affecting the market
you know whether it's um
you know characters like elon musk for
example you know pumping doge or
whatever it is so i'd love to get your
take on how
that there's like a shift between
between like serious stocks whether it's
like tech stocks to more jokes and how
powerful that internet culture is
it's definitely powerful right like i
don't think even the internet knew how
powerful it was until gamestop
we'd had inklings of it before like in
2020 when the pandemic was in full force
um hurts the uh rental car company
declared bankruptcy because nobody was
traveling and renting cars
so the stock was like two dollars a
share was pretty close to zero and so
all the people from wall street bets are
like uh yeah you're supposed to buy low
and sell high
and two dollars is pretty low it's
pretty close to zero there's a lot more
numbers if you go up than if you go down
so let's buy this stock right like it's
just you know the thought flawed but
actually somewhat legitimate logic where
it's like yeah if it goes to zero i'll
lose 100 percent right big deal but it
can go like you know it can double or
triple sure enough and what doubler to
tripled and and people like that's cool
then
around the same time you had this uh
like people are like oh everyone has to
work from home you have to use zoom and
so of course everyone says let's buy
zoom
and the logic of buying a company
because there's a lot of users is is
okay but but it's not complete right it
doesn't mean that a company is going to
be profitable
uh so so critics serious critics are
saying these guys don't know what
they're doing did you think because more
customers means better business why
wouldn't it though wait pause why
wouldn't it because to me i feel dumb
for not buying zoom stock no i mean it's
it's okay like that analysis is okay
because it's going to mean more revenue
and it gives them kind of more options
if they're not profitable but if you
have if you're in the stage of your
business where you have negative unit
economics meaning like you're losing
price per customer because all
businesses have this kind of a
j curve the majority of them do where
they start off like at zero zero and
then you start losing money for every
unit that you sell or service that okay
and then eventually you turn into
profitability that's uh if
you know if you don't have your numbers
correctly then then
having
servers are overwhelming you have to
scale up the right time and then the
thing goes down at about time because
you weren't ready there's a lot of
things right but understand yeah but
regardless of it people are saying yeah
this logic is incomplete and then not
only was that the case these these
people also just went out and bought the
wrong zoom because it was like a ticker
symbol
the word zoom z-o-o-m
as opposed to the correct ticker that
was zm so people are buying the wrong
company
on the wrong premise and that stock went
up like 300 percent the wrong the wrong
stock right i didn't know this that's
wild so so people that were saying you
silly you guys are idiots you don't know
what you're doing
like you bought the wrong company and
these guys are like yeah but i made more
money than if i bought the right company
so who cares go back to your suit right
like
we're having fun over here we're making
money we just killed it with hurts we
just killed it with the wrong zoom let's
keep killing it with whatever else we
decide to find
that's amazing i love it it really is
empowering um
but you know with
crypto these days and you know you
mentioned defy and liquidity pools and
yield farming and and everything that's
going on right now how relevant do you
think stocks are
you know it's it's an existential
question for me because i
have the majority of my experience in
stocks and in finance and
when bitcoin or some of these first
currencies came out i was like this is
cool right my economics hat says all
right this is an interesting concept you
have this currency and it can't be
destructible and it's
got scarcity built into it and it's got
this technological component so i was
like all right well i hope they make it
it's a cool experiment um
you know and i was mining it at first uh
and and and then it was just difficult
and i just kind of it was really
cumbersome to to use it so then i was
just went back to stocks and i just
watched from the uh you know from the
sidelines as the price went up and i'm
like okay cool they made it right
bitcoin well yeah were you wait but what
yeah were you mining
oh early like and i lost oh my god so
don't worry it was like 2013.
yeah but you know i don't kick myself in
the butt because if i had like 100
bitcoins i would have sold it when i was
like three dollars right i wouldn't have
waited till it was at 60. so i i
at least that's what i tell myself um i
agree so
uh
but anyway so the the
the st sorry people start buying pizzas
with bitcoin on cool they made it right
this experiment was successful um back
to my stocks now and all of a sudden you
start seeing these other coins pop up in
ethereum that's not the other like oh
cool all right now there's more of them
all right interesting but there's just
numbers on the screen that go up and
down it's another asset but it doesn't
plug into my broker so not interested
they don't know no stock options on on
on cryptos so i'll just stick to this
for now on the liquidity
and so i never reevaluated that stance i
just kept assuming that it was just
coins and then i'm watching like the
2017-18 the ico boom and i'm seeing
everybody doing these new coins i'm like
that's kind of that's annoying right um
but but whatever more coins that go up
and down it's just gonna muddy the
waters
and then this last year i was approached
by some i got approached a bazillion
times for people like pop my coin
and then last year uh this this one
group people said no no help like come
with us we're gonna do a cool thing
where we're gonna merge stocks with
nice with crypto and i'm like all right
that's something i could get behind and
so all of a sudden i popped the hood on
this this crypto thing i was like wait
guys this is more than just coins did
you know that you can like
do this automated market like there's
there's
there's a way there's a market that's
decentralized and the computer decides
based off of these things that's genius
right like it's different because order
books from centralized exchanges have
their merits but but they also have
their flaws so like how did somebody
come up with these things and then you
look at these liquidity pools then i'm
looking at these smart contract
derivatives also where you have
these leveraged etfs for
bitcoin or whatever these things so that
you can buy leveraged up or leverage
down
and
and as i start using an
experiment i'd like to buy stuff and
figure out how they work later you know
i realize that these etfs
that are very similar to the ones you
have in the regular stock market that
are leveraged um they had one
different component where you have the
smart contract that that evaluates the
condition of the of the underlying so
that if it's ranging so if the price is
pretty much staying where it is the
leverage goes down and if it starts
trending meaning if it shoots up or
shoots down
the leverage also gets cranked up um
there's a lot of math of what happens
next but essentially that fixes this
flaw that these leveraged instruments
have that make them go to zero with like
near 100
certainty over time right so i'm like
wait wait wait wait crypto has this
smart like etf that can adjust based off
of rules and that makes you more money
like why doesn't wall street have that
what's going on
and they don't close on the weekends i
knew that right but like but i felt
the benefits of it yeah especially when
elon musk does goes out there and tweets
something it's on a sunday about tesla
and you have these synthetic stocks that
trade 24 7. i'm like yeah i think i'll
go short this now on on the blockchain
even if i don't have the stock like it's
just it's a price tracker basically but
like monday morning opens up and boom
i'm like free money i'm like all right
so i'm realizing this ridiculous
sophisticated intelligent like ecosystem
where people can interact financially
and it's a heck of a lot more than just
a coin whose price is
up or down right and so then i regret
not reevaluating my stance earlier on
because i think that there's uh a very
evident trend where the the the the
lines are blurring between stocks and
crypto and i'm involved currently with
the wall street bets dap
uh which does just that like we're
creating etfs that have like a it's like
a basket of mix you can either get
crypto with stocks or whatever um or
just stocks or just crypto and
um and you can buy these synthetics or
you can buy these collateralized stocks
they'll be synthetic stocks right but
they're both yeah so right now we have
synthetic stocks and we just we just
closed the deal which we're launching at
any
moment here in the next coming weeks
where you'll actually be able to
purchase
collateralized stocks um so this is this
is where you buy a crypto thing and that
crypto thing
represents a stock that somebody goes
out and buys and passes you the
dividends and the shareholder rights
obviously when you do that you have to
go through the kyc component because you
can't get a dividend or you can't vote
on a company unless people know who you
are but it's done everything through the
blockchain and these guys trade 20 hours
a day uh seven days a week which is
which is crazy i have no idea how they
do it but they do it and we've partnered
with them fully regulated all these
things so so it's like let's blur the
lines and you have etfs on the in wall
street that have you know they have the
bitcoin etf that's been trying forever
finally got a bitcoin's future etf i
don't understand
yeah you know why do you say no to one
and yes to the future is one but
whatever gotta walk before you can run i
guess yeah and so like these things are
kind of blurring and
and so the whole thing of well is it
like stock's relevant or is crypto gonna
be the new thing it's like yeah they can
they're gonna both exist right they're
gonna be the same thing jp morgan i keep
reading about this metaverse thing that
they're doing and
you know like it's it's evident that
the wall street people also realize that
there's this thing in crypto and
various and brokers like robin hood you
can already buy both as if they're
stocks so that difference is kind of
breaking down but i will say this that
i'm talking that's from the perspective
of the retail trader right like you and
me that want to just make money
um you have a component of
the the business which is why does a
stock exist
and it's for so businesses can raise
money at least you know in theory that's
what was created for and can still be
used for that effect and occasionally it
is um
so to that effect just say well no
companies are not going to stop going
public because companies are going to
pop up all the time and they're going to
want to either raise money or pay back
their early investors and that's how you
do that part
uh however i i'm now counting the days
before companies go public on the
blockchain i mean they already do it's
happening yeah yeah they already do but
they're just not like the official
you know ring the bell at the nasdaq or
the new york stock exchange type going
public with the sec regulation things
you have these projects these dowels
these nft things they all these coins
that do stuff like they're fully
operational businesses and they release
their thing and they raise a lot of
money with it and
and then they operate like this
it looks different because a lot of
these are like anonymous or
decentralized or whatever but but they
already happen
and there's a ton of benefits to that so
i'm waiting for the days for the next
like
i don't know airbnb or whatever official
company to go on the blockchain instead
of on
on wall street because there are so many
benefits to that like for starters you
know who your shareholders are right
without knowing their name necessarily
but like
but you can send them a message like
thank you or come see my webinar or
whatever right like that's something
that they
they can sort of do it but it's really
difficult for companies to know their
shoulders are
uh the only thing that's missing is
regulatory components i think that
that's the only reason why they haven't
done it yet
there's so much to unpack there um we
can get into regulation and all of that
but before we do i want to understand
fully your
if there is a philosophical reason at
all behind your interest in crypto i
know obviously you know you were sort of
going through it and you know you
realize wow there's defy automated
market makers and and all this stuff but
like
in times of
decentralization and stuff like that do
you feel a kind of passion towards
again taking back that control not
having that centralized control
basically
yes and no um you know bitcoin launches
around the same time that wall street
bets does and the language around
bitcoin
obviously there's a lot of different
voices but one of the one of the voices
that was heard a lot was what you just
said decentralized take back control
central banks fiat printing
blah blah blah um
you know and in my case i was also angry
at the system uh
because i'd been impacted by by this
crisis i'm thinking all right well if
you can't beat them join them we're not
going to be able to beat them at their
own game so might as well make money but
the motivation was
was parallel it was a different approach
to it right so bitcoin tries to take on
the system head on i'm just like well
let's just ride the wave along with them
there's no reason why we should fight it
uh and and these philosophies kind of
evolve like i'm not a activist i'm not a
you know [ __ ] the central bank or i feel
like i you're not you're not going to
get rid of that and there's a lot of
benefits to that all right i i can go
um toe to toe with with
people that are knowledgeable on this
and hold my own when it comes to to
defending
the existence and acknowledging the
flaws with the ex with the existing
systems that set up these these
centralized institutions i get both
sides but but i also get that you won't
get rid of them but you don't have to
get you don't have to have a winner
these things already co-exist right
china tries to ban bitcoin twice a year
and they still can't right and they
won't be able to because it's part of
the
you know it's one of the one of the
features of bitcoin is you can't just
like there's no setting to say if if
china then don't right like yeah
so so you already have countries like el
salvador you know i've read today that
ukraine is accepting bitcoin i don't
know what that means that came out four
months ago that that ukraine legalizing
bitcoin but what does that mean what
does that mean ukraine accepts bitcoin
like
you have a wallet
i send you a wallet okay are you like
where are you
these the
what's cool about like crypto is like it
doesn't ask you where you're living
before you like use it right like it's
in the us they have some restrictions if
you want to use centralized
exchanges or whatever but for the most
part like you know it's just what it do
you have an address is it valid okay i'm
going to go ahead and use it so whatever
whatever that means about um ukraine i i
think it solved or slightly different
because the salvatore is purchasing it
right so that's totally different
completely different so but anyway so
you have you have this this coexisting
that's taking place and
and i'm cool with that but i'll tell you
what motivates me it's not like ah we're
gonna get rid of
you know what power is it be
because i like the powers b if it wasn't
because of the powers we wouldn't have
wall street bets we need wall street in
order to have wall street bets
um but there's a lot of problems with it
i acknowledge them all most of them some
of them i disagree with
and let's fix them so let's try and fix
this like one of the things that i said
is this thing is a casino right i don't
think it's fun that people use this like
a casino because last time you did that
people lost their house i lost my job
so i can complain about i can [ __ ]
about it and put a tent in front of wall
street and just hold up a sign for a few
months
or i can try and make them outraged and
so one of these things that i
started doing before the pandemic and
then canceled it but now restarting it
is
you know i'm getting this venue at a
casino in las vegas and it's like a big
stadium type thing and putting uh an
esports setup where you have like these
10
12 competitors on the stage with their
computers you know crowd streaming
online and these people are going to be
trading with the stocks as if it was a
video game and they'll be actually
trading the stocks right and you're
going to have the guys that are saying
oh this you know he's taking the iron
condor with tesla which is like a stock
options thing and you know that means
that by friday this thing has to do that
and then you know and and have people
that are like a dave portnoy individual
and like a gem creamer and just
all sorts of characters
and just make a video game spectacle out
of the stock market and why would i want
to do that
because i think the system is broken but
i can do that right it's perfectly legal
i've checked many times obviously
so if like people are pissed like how
can these guys be using a las vegas
casino to play with the stock market
like a freaking video game it's amazing
it's sponsored by esports things right
like
and it's because i want to elicit that
change if you don't like it fix it and
that's
that's my attitude and crypto
does a lot of things to fix finance
right and it doesn't have to replace one
or the other but you can rub off on it
like what do i mean let's just start
with 24 hour day trading like why that's
that is a setting unlike the bitcoin
china thing like you know it trading
hours equals 24 enter compile send
whatever upload like
you get to go there's no reason why
market shouldn't be 24 7 and i don't
complain because i want to be up at
three in the morning but i complain
because occasionally china says we're
defaulting with everground or whatever
you know
you have these things that happen after
hours and those are liquidity events
that really screw up the system and it
causes these crazy like domino effects
and it's bad it's systemically bad so
don't turn it off anymore so crypto can
rub off on on wall street in that effect
and that's a good thing
you have these smart contract etfs
they're brilliant these are like
intelligent things that actually change
based off of conditions like
awesome that helps people make money and
not just gamble it actually helps
serious people too
you can make
you know i was trying to come up with
when i uh
a rewind i give a lot of talks right i
go to the
you know people invite me to comment and
speak to these audiences and sometimes
half the time they're they're crypto the
other half the time there's stocks and
they're very binary they're like they're
hardcore on whichever side they are and
i i will go to these serious investor
forums and i'll talk about wall street
bets and they want to hear about game
stop it and then i'll bring up crypto
because it's relevant and looking at me
like but crypto what's an nfc why would
i buy it
what's a thing and why would i buy a
pyramid scheme whatever
and then i'll go to bitcoin conferences
or crypto conferences and i will talk
about both and i'll talk about stocks
because people are curious about the
thing with the game stuff
and then they stop like what is a stock
and why would you buy it and why is it
not a pyramid scheme right
and so both questions from both sides is
fundamentally the same right like and
they're both fundamentally right
so
that's so funny yeah so if if you're
able to have crypto
sorry sorry i remember saying so
crypto's able to actually do stuff in a
much better way like i i try to come up
with an example for my stock friends of
saying well what can you do in crypto
that you can't do in stocks i challenge
you yeah so i thought about it for a
while and i said all right well
you know i i thought of these um
liquidity pools and these uh prediction
markets
as as an example like you can already
today based off of stuff that currently
exists it's not a hypothetical
set up a thing that if you own a ski
resort um
you know mountain where people ski and
you're worried about the snowfall
because if it doesn't snow people don't
ski
you want to hedge against that
um yeah you can set up a thing on the on
the decentralized smart contract blah
blah liquidity thing where you say i'm
going to short sell inches of snow and
and
crypto has these oracles that go out and
read to make sure you can trust the
weather reports
and
and if it snows
you know you're supposed to short sell
60 inches because that's the amount you
need in order to fill your mountain
right if it's it only snows 30 then you
can cash out your short sale of snow
30 inches like very to a very granular
level right and the counterparty is this
decentralized prediction market where
it's not you don't have a counterparty
risk like it's a very intelligent system
and you know if it snows your 60 inches
you close out your your trade at a very
small loss
and that's the price of your insurance
policy and like that's done on the fly
today right like do do that wall street
you have to fill out applications and do
things and sec you know like it's just
not possible so that's cool and i think
that's really really powerful
and how do you think regulation is then
going to affect this
i mean
it's in a really good way like
regulation lack of regulation is the
only thing holding
crypto back
uh
people to what extent though
so like
what they legalized marijuana in the us
in certain states or they started by
decriminalizing it and
in the us you'd have like colorado they
say well you can come to my store and
you can buy
marijuana because here it's legal but
the federal government says this is not
legal you can't do that and banks are
regulated by the federal government so
people couldn't use banks to operate
their store right so now some of these
stores have to take cash and they're
exposed to this kind of like crazy risk
or whatever if you went up to an
investor says dear investor please
invest in my pot shop the investor says
you're all cash business and you care
like how are you going to pay me back
yeah duffel bags and cat like i don't
so all of a sudden you have to regulate
it and all of a sudden you can use the
banks also like
and there's rules they say you can do
this and you can't do that then
everyone's like all right cool i'll
invest in your in your companies and you
have like all these beer companies that
are pouring heavy money into the
marijuana market
and it's growing so regulation is going
to do the same thing if you set up put a
set of rules and say hey
these are the rules you can do this and
you can't do that and you have to apply
here and you need to fill out that form
to do that
we can kick and screen because it's
going to be more annoying right used to
be better than before and now you have
to do this thing and that sucks
but thanks to that thing that sucks uh
now you'll have
a lot of money pouring into this thing
and yeah fixing a lot of problems and
i'll tell you one of the problems that i
that i currently still have with crypto
like
it is very difficult to use when i first
bought sorry when i got into this thing
i was like how do i buy my own coin my
wall street bets coin like oh it's easy
just download metamask and you have to
set up the network so that you can have
bsc which is not to be confused like a
bep20 thing as opposed to a bep2 because
that thing is not going to make you lose
all your money goes away if you screw
that up it's done because china you know
blockchain's immutable then you have to
open the browser inside the thing like
jesus christ like how do you do this and
i think in large part that problem
hasn't been fixed yet because
of regulation so
is it gonna is it's gonna hinder certain
stuff yes but the number of things that
it will empower
is going to far out number and let me
point one last thing out
um
if you're able to say all right crypto
is legal but only if you use bitcoin any
other derivative like the only one we
will allow you to do in the u.s is
bitcoin and you know taxes and business
and that uh
and then people are like well that sucks
because bitcoin you know it's good but
but but there's a lot of better ones out
there right
but you kind of have to sort of take
that and say all right well i'm going to
make my bitcoin amazon or whatever like
some big ass empire and now you're
making a lot of money and i like i
really hate bitcoin because it's
screwing up my transactions i'm going to
take some of my billions and i'm going
to put a lobbyist right in front of
washington i'm going to ask him to allow
us to use ethereum now something that we
all really know but we haven't been able
to do because we don't have that
formalized structure and next thing you
know you'll have these lobbyists and
interest groups all these things are
actually doing these things and they'll
have to fix legislation i i had this one
idea that i love i was like why don't we
just give congress all members of
congress an nft and say hey hold on to
this thing
this nft is going to entitle you to an
airdrop
once a month you get millions of dollars
for the duration of life as long as the
mechanism by which you're receiving this
air drop continues to be legal right so
all you need to do is don't [ __ ] it up
like don't change the rules so that this
becomes illegal because then we need to
comply with the law and just cut off
your like free money since congress all
you do is look for money and that's
that's what you do
that is brilliant that is actually such
an interesting idea um just moving on a
little bit and we don't actually need to
go into this um i feel like i should
have asked you before um but i wondered
if you've been following anything that's
been going on in canada
i have loosely i'm i'm ashamed to say i
don't know the intricacies
uh but i work with uh several people
very closely that are in canada so i'm
aware but i get different takes of it
right like i'll see the twitter takes
and they'll just say like canada the
truck drivers and you know the
cryptocurrencies
right and then and then i'll get the
takes from my partners like yeah they're
trying to annex or not the next what's
the
you know they're trying to break off and
make a different country out of ontario
or quebec or whatever you know like who
the truck is i don't know what they're
doing
they're just uh so so i so i i'm ashamed
to say i don't fully appreciate the
nuance of what's going on i understand
that they're sick of covet like the rest
of the world and they're using that as
an excuse and the truck drivers are
doing
um the thing that they find most
annoying and you know they're doing this
quite effectively
yeah i mean the reason i brought this up
was because the um
the prime minister justin trudeau has
said that they'll be freezing the bank
accounts of those who are
people who are supposedly involved so a
lot of people are looking to obviously
bitcoin and as an alternative so i just
wondered if you had any thoughts on that
but if you're not following it then no
no i did i did see that and that
actually yeah that explains all of the
if you use crypto you don't need
something
like i was like there's a lot of tweets
about this today um yeah that's silly
right like i you know i think the first
catalyst for
bitcoin if i remember correctly was in
2013
when cyprus was is this yeah separate
haircut they defaulted or thing and then
they they froze up bank accounts or cash
phones or atm machines whatever like
they they did a thing that really pissed
off the people that had they took
they took money from people and you
couldn't get you couldn't like move your
money to a safe place and so bitcoin was
this really great way to do that and
people are like wow you mean this thing
works like across countries
um
anyway so i think that that's already in
people's heads for a decade so i'm
surprised that justin said this but like
i will say this
as i'm following bitcoin and i'm like
early on and i'm looking at the price it
goes up and down and people are saying
this is gonna the central bank and power
of the people and all these things and
you will never need to use a bank
account anymore i'm like ah that's kind
of annoying you activist you know just
tone it down a few notches your bank's
not going anywhere all right like relax
um
and i keep hearing it forever and it
doesn't go away even still today
literally you know now we're talking
about canada
then i start using crypto and mind you i
live in mexico city but i grew up in the
us i like international as it is and i
have banking in both countries make
money in both countries
um
you know i i at one point
figure out how to use crypto to
facilitate my life
and all of a sudden i find myself like
you know i get a lot of money
i'm getting yeah i'm getting a lot of
money with crypto and so i'm doing all
the kyc with the old broker so i can put
it into my bank and i do that in mexico
and i do in the us i'm like putting all
this money into my bank i'm like cool
this is not just funny money it's real
money
you know i go to the atm to withdraw and
i can feel it and then all of a sudden
i'm like why did i just put that into my
bank
that was kind of silly right and all of
a sudden like you know what why not just
keep it all in crypto and i'll follow
myself find myself taking the money
that's in my bank so i think i should
put this in crypto
and next thing you know i'm looking at
myself and i'm like why would i use a
bank why would anyone ever use a bank
but i don't dare say it out loud because
then i'm gonna be labeled this activist
that says like you know oh shut up
you're just trying to like promote your
cryptocurrencies i'm like no you don't
understand like this thing is so much
better and it works and it's just
like you know how expensive it is i just
i i do these things and i just it was
miami a couple months ago and we did
this big event and it cost a quarter
million dollars to put together i'm
running all these transactions it is a
ginormous pain in the ass like we still
haven't been able to do all the
transactions because
because banks and they get in the way
and i'm like you know i'm calling the
venue and i'm like yeah i'm gonna give
you like 80 000 deposit but like my
bank's only letting me do it in 5 000
increments using venmo or whatever right
and i'm like
sorry this is going to take a week to
get your deposit but like i can't fly to
the us to
you know i call the bank of like can i
write him a check they're like no
because you can set off too many red
flags i'm like but what red flags this
money came from crypto i've already set
off the flags like trust me
and and all of a sudden you know but all
of a sudden i start doing those
transactions like crypto and i'm like
well that was easy
yeah and i think it like
we will get to a place where we don't
necessarily need banks i mean i know
that it does sound kind of wacky um but
like i i was in miami a few months ago
and i paid for my accommodation using
crypto um the airbnb because they saw
who i was so they were like
we'll take we'll take bitcoin and i was
like i won't give you bitcoin but i'll
give you eth okay if they were like
that's fine we'll take
um so i did that i paid my optician in
miami as well i needed to get some new
contact lenses so i paid him in tether
um and yeah i paid for a lot of things i
think even i actually just got on
another apartment in miami and the guy
asked me to pay him in bitcoin and i was
like absolutely not
so
we
i mean yeah yes and no because here
here's the thing here's a reason why
banks will be really difficult go away
in order to get rid of banks you need to
get rid of fiat and you're not getting
rid of feedback in time so you don't
think we will eventually you can't
because i'll tell you i'll tell you what
fiat is really good for i'm going to
tell you about letting you know on a
secret cash is great for crimes and for
like laundering money and for doing bad
things and that stuff isn't going away
anytime soon
but that's the funny thing because
there's like this narrative that crypto
you know especially bitcoin is um
criminal and it helps enable criminal
activity but it's cash cash is the best
most anonymous form
i don't know where did that what did
that st like who came up with that like
this this concept of bitcoin is
anonymous because like this thing's like
well you registered an account it didn't
ask me for my name i'm like all right
cool like look at these guys that just
got nabbed the bitfinex you know the
yeah they were all over the news you
know they had like billions of dollars
worth of bitcoin and they were able to
launder a little bit of it right and
they slipped up at some point that's how
they got caught but like what what
catches my attention is how difficult it
was for them to unsuccessfully mind you
launder a little bit of that money why
because at some point if you want to use
the money you have to reveal your
identity this whole idea you know mixed
coin mixers all these things like you
have big data stuff they can figure it
all out right you have either computers
that will attract the things or
computers that can they can monitor for
suspicious activity just like the nsa is
using metadata to figure you know they
don't need your name in order to know
that you're a terrorist because the
patterns right the same thing with the
bitcoin like
terrible terrible way to like
launder money or to do criminal activity
so that's why i don't think you can get
rid of fiat because there's a huge
enterprise because it's useful yeah
that's hilarious that is actually so
funny um so just finally then jamie
because it's me so interesting i'm
speaking with you i asked people
actually i'm gonna ask you team quite
two more questions which um people ask
me to ask you so the first question i
ask you is um your father works at the
is it the world economic
world economic forum so the question is
what does he do there and how do you
feel about him working for that
organization
um i i did see that question by the way
you have like the coolest followers
right
i've done a gazillion interviews and
podcasts and all these things and
the only person that's ever asked me
about my dad
has been a mexican journalist and that's
because my dad is
somewhat famous in mexico so actually my
dad is
this guy right here behind me the guy
that's on my
far
left right whatever side it is
he's he doesn't work at the world
economic forum but he was part of the
world economic forum he was like a
global global leader of tomorrow which
is like now called young global leaders
thing but but he is a institutional
banker central bank whatever he's run a
bunch of uh national you know mexican
national uh development banks as well as
multilateral banks and he's worked with
you know the imf and the all the all the
three literal acronyms and banks that
you can possibly imagine okay and he is
like crazy conservative right like his
house he buys it in cash right and he
understands he's got a
phd in economics guy understands things
right but he's like yeah i get the time
value of money thing but yeah i'm not i
don't want a mortgage i want my deed his
cars he pays in cash like all these
things he just does not take risks like
he was running a bank during the 2008
financial crisis his bank was the only
one like one of three in the world that
had zero exposure to these asset-backed
securities
yeah those things look like they pay you
too much money and there's no free money
uh get him off the books
um so he's like the anti-me in that
respect right because i'm like yolo
where's the thing to the moon here's my
analysis
and i'm kicking wall street like in the
nuts with all these crazy things that
are happening
uh but he
is as smart as he is he has he is a
strong out-of-the-box thinker he's
always been a very unique
problem solver and very unique approach
his style is completely different than
mine but he instilled that
unique thinker approach right and i
think that and and he went through the
conservative politics kind of avenue and
he's very successful with that um but i
think he vicariously
like is envious of my position because i
can get away with so much stuff and and
i can really ridicule a lot of stuff
without having any political blowback uh
repercussions right now oftentimes he
actually like he's like you should say
this next time like
somebody asks you about that because he
doesn't have the ability to but um
but he's an excellent excellent role
model and uh and we're polar opposite
but he loves what i do secretly he'll
never publicly admit it
that's brilliant no that's brilliant um
and then the final question was what is
the next gme
that's a good question um it's tricky so
gme like
i i don't know i don't know what it is
and it's impossible to tell i can tell
you kind of one of the
uh telltale signs as it's building up
but like there is no next gma because
prior to gme there wasn't necessarily a
stock there was a
i don't know the infinite margin thing
that i told you about and prior to that
there was like this box spreads thing or
like there's always people
that are what was the one that i saw the
other day
one that dealt with warrants on the
donald trump's bag right this was an
interesting arb where you have this back
which is like a stock we'll just call it
that um
it trades a certain amount but the
warrants are trading in another amount
and there's a reason for that but that
reason is dumb and therefore it
legitimately is a free trade for anyone
that knows how to buy one and sell the
other one
that's the type that's the next gme
right like
it's this cheat code where there's free
money it's on the table
gme was not just a stock whose price
went up it was a stock whose price went
astronomically up like a lot and
the reason why that went up so much
had to do with a lot of factors outside
of just people buying it which dealt
with the short sellers with the stock
options whatever
the market is learned
from their um
uh from whatever
they want they won't allow that to
happen again using that same maneuver
but i'll tell you what the things if you
start seeing a lot of chatter stocks are
going up and you see everyone's talking
about it everywhere and you start seeing
it on the news
there is your next gma
okay well i will have to keep my eyes
open for it because i need to
have a bite of this pie i think that's
what they say something like that um
jamie where can people follow you how
can they um join wall street bets just
show yourself for us yeah just uh follow
me on on twitter it's at wall street
bets all spelled out um or the website
that that i'm working with is wall
street bets.net as far as where can they
join wall street best look there's the
reddit there's discord there's telegram
there's tick-tock there's the you know
find the one you like facebook
and it's it's all the same things for
different countries there's wall street
that's india and china and south korea
and then there's like
specific assets like silver and gold so
just google it and enjoy
that's amazing you've just created an
entire movement um and i'm just i'm
really just like in awe of the whole
movement and everything that it
represents and i think you know how it's
sort of empowering i do like the
narrative of it and powers the little
man because i think it is true and i
know i i think it's brilliant so jamie
thank you so much for coming on the show
today yes thank you very much for having
me this was fun
yeah absolutely and guys thank you so
much for watching don't forget to tune
in this week next week next week for
another brilliant guest until next time
we'll see you then
[Music]